just how am i doing
we had such a good episode I felt really
good about it
you got the vaccine I did I got a full
you wanna check that although don't
vaccines aren't a preventative yeah you
want a cure an of X that's true like the
translation team kind of [ __ ] that one
up okay what if I give it to her and
she's like if only I didn't have it you
idiot yeah
wait so I'm pretty sure you're gonna
fight the nemesis is Carlos that seems
right grab some [ __ ] like all your
health from the box
oh really yeah like say yeah okay well I
don't have any ammo like Carlos saúl
rifles good I got a knife could i knife
him no just so I really don't mind
I really don't have that much I got some
Reds I got a red suitcase I guess maybe
I see greens on the way
I don't think Reds even bring out red on
in case you run into a green on the way
okay you're gonna say I have to know the
Dodge I have them Dodge I got the Dodge
on lock okay all right here we go
hey baby I'm back it's me Carlos
got all that [ __ ] um uh what's that at
four seconds
yeah you should uh where am I going do
you activate the bomb or leave running
Wow good thing you save for that
oh that is dumb
I had five seconds I wonder if you could
have gone back in the save room like
what would happen because they must
realize that people have to save or not
save there dude imagine if I didn't save
I would have been pissed
there was like nothing I could do like
man this game has a lot more like
balancing problems than wanted to did
[Music]
thing to make me learn how to do and the
thing is is if you want to have like
that limbo thing you know like where you
have to die in order to understand what
you're supposed to do
you probably shouldn't have it have
optional saves that are really limited
yeah that would really screw people over
alright well I think that's the name of
the Japanese version is game biohazard
last escape
I think alright so put my disks away and
he'll take home Gregor but I actually I
still don't understand what was I
supposed to do either just run out the
front door or go to try to defuse the I
would say run out the front where okay
so I take a left immediately it's
literally right your shoulders gonna
bump up okay
biohazard three last escape I was right
she cared okay sorry it's like in the
shot I just like I think the bomb based
timer really freaked me out
what a weird thing
I ran the wrong way
[Music]
like the Dark Knight well
Hospital is now definitely gone mm-hmm
all right so I should just give her the
virus right let make sense vaccine oh
right but still that makes no sense
I don't think unless like it hasn't
incubated yeah hopefully just dodged
because you want to use that all against
the nemi all right let me plan this out
it's a straight to the left got it and
then in Mayan spider town I can't
remember
[Music]
spider done
okay she's looking right at one is he
yeah it's so right and then run like
hell go oh he hurt me yeah I hope you're
not poison cuz you read fine you know
you're Cheston I have a blue there's a
blue herb up ahead yeah but I think is
your where you're fighting the nemesis
I'm on caution don't don't worry about
that yet then
where am I going I forget again I'm
going straight down I'm going to go to
the right main room
those little spiders are gone at least
that doesn't make me feel any better
where are they all right so there should
be Oh balls so you think I should take
him on yeah I think it makes it easier
it's a fight as Jill later because he's
really hard to kill in tentacle form
right so you're supposed to not to it
yeah I hope you're hitting it
Oh follow him I think you can kill Jill
because he's hunting Jilly the Stars
member sure right it makes sense
wait maybe I think you can just I don't
know if you want to kill now you're
gonna get to jail maybe you want to
shoot him I honestly don't know at this
point
yeah because you're gonna go back to
jail - I'd say fight him [ __ ] damn he's
already tired yeah we get it game [ __ ]
I'm curious I'm not gonna tell you in a
really rough life for me yikes
what happens when I eat a red herb I
don't think it does anything unless it's
combined do it at least in their earlier
can I combine a red and a blue yeah no
I'm it will seal your poison but it
won't heal me at all the pain in the
butt I don't
I don't know what to do
what did you learn don't lie to me
no I think we're on the right track
okay killed by bomb killed by nemesis oh
you can actually deactivate the bomb it
helps you later go up to the bomb you
just saved I felt like I was being too
generous
this whole playthrough you can't
deactivate the bomb you're actually like
a bad thing yeah sorry I want you to do
anything
all right like literally the first five
minutes of this episode been wasted five
or 15 of them bum-bum-bum alright wait
[Music]
I don't want to do this again I do not
care for you and your antics yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right so I still don't know what to
do and I feel like I need to heal to
take on the nemesis because he's going
to hit me like me multiple times you
know yeah okay don't fight him actually
no no it's not enough evidence to
support doing it well he's gonna go
after Jill right yeah but it's not gonna
you're gonna have to fight him as Jill
anyway
damn it I'm having exact same problem as
last time
tip-in try to fight him this time
I can you can't yeah but I'll just die
again cuz he's way too strong now you
can save his Jill right after when she
wakes up apparently isn't she's not
saving so I don't understand though like
does he come after me in this room or
does he avoid me total to come in to say
no this guy can I fight him in this room
why does he leave you just go anyway
he's gonna chase Jill it's just a show
just go to Jill but he he comes after me
when I follow up I run away
[Music]
you want me to run away run toward Jill
okay beat him to her
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
he's gonna kill me should I use it sure
still one eating go now whoa I like was
spamming that button I promise
so I'm fairly confident he's not allowed
to come through until he can't see that
door I was told from someone once before
so you're not gonna I don't think you're
in get the best reward from killing him
cuz that's like if you fought him every
time I think but something so should I
fight him or not sure I mean if you say
right before them we could just engage
it as Jill or now is Jill okay stars
all right what am i doing wait
this right yeah yes
what happened oh my god
I love you
[Music]
she's been through some [ __ ] hey are you
okay
maybe you do get this I'd fight him
barely save hear them what's going on
okay
no way that monster just doesn't give up
what I thought we killed that thing
no it's been waiting for you it's gonna
be hard though did he bring the Magnum
okay
he's playing with this shotgun Carlos do
you think that it's unstoppable
now everything go I don't think so
I'm sorry Joe but I've got to go take
care of a few things
Oh glad to run from the nemesis Nicola
is still alive
Nikolai are you sure that's what I lie
to you
I don't know how but I do know that he
is our enemy
remember don't trust him
okay so let us prepare for our argument
okay so all right let's prep first right
and then save that way I don't have to
do this every time
spring magnet got manga Browns again
let's let's look it up shall we
file I'm gonna find it first
magnumcy C&C in your face how do you
make see uh do you I don't think you
can't make see nice I haven't yet I
don't think I have any see Oh way no to
create gunpowder see makes gunpowder a
and B together that's horseshit that's
not on here wait no I don't know try
mixing a and B damn c is created by
mixing a and B I was like a big dum-dum
alright so we're just gonna make a [ __ ]
ton of magnums is that what we're doing
right maybe you should save first so
then if we [ __ ] this up and you actually
can't ruin an assist with like 12 Magnum
bullets then we didn't waste up
gunpowder are you sure yeah
at least this time this is like such a
pain to redo and I'll bet it'll be worth
it alright so save
I know I will so what I can do and what
I propose is mix AAA and Amick giant a
make mix BBB make giant B makes a giant
a and giant B does that do anything I
don't it should make a giant C shouldn't
it know what I don't know so much about
this game I don't understand
so there's B there's a be Oh big dum-dum
there's an a there's an a wait am I out
of B I'm only gonna work anyway okay so
that's all I have I don't think that's
enough grenade rounds if you wanna make
those and so that's the wait don't do
that yet hon it was C plus C do it makes
for easier to see no it doesn't it'll
make 10 freeze around oh are you sure
yeah
do you want that I would wait until you
get another a and B so you can make a
mag
oh no no you're fine just put those blue
in there
wait you have a Gump our area there
right yeah have a I just I have to
[ __ ] on a that's what's so
disappointing about all this money I
wasted all my B oh I wasted all my be
your shotgun rounds I have a [ __ ] ton of
shotgun rounds look at look how much I
[ __ ] this up I have 30 [ __ ] shots I
just use that against them users that's
it dodge notices no I will go through so
much health I'll die whatever I've got a
weapon that'll make it easy like I need
grenades or something ring I'm so
disappointed with my freaking give
grenades right now health gonna bring a
red yeah combine this this isn't enough
to fight him up definitely a [ __ ] die
no bring up there one more red but bring
a I think you want the lockpick actually
if you're gonna fight him to bring the
lockpick why cuz you can't so you don't
come to have to go back here but I have
to fight him right but if you beat him
you want to come back here
du-uh are those are mine throw rounds to
the left of that up and down up and left
combine those two I am in the box right
now yeah this point I wonder if it's
even word they carry that's why we saved
it'll be good I'm so disappointed I made
all those [ __ ] shotgun shells just
use that then you just have to you'll
get him just you just have to run to his
right side every time that's the one
you're supposed to run to be good
a few more grenade rounds but no
definitely don't bring the Magnum what's
an MT round again my throw so so I could
use the mine thrower you just got to
make sure you dodge and shoot and then
dodge and shoot a couple times where you
just have to be decent at dodging which
you've been lately you bad I'm so
disappointed with myself it's my choice
[ __ ] I can't believe I wasted all yeah
one more gunpowder see you make 24
magnum rounds so you'll be fine yeah but
I don't I don't have it now whatever I'm
doing all right let's get a layout of
the room again
is this an open room this is somewhat
the piano yep I don't know if he's in
here or not though worried [ __ ] I'm I
just went to kill him am I supposed to
be doing anything - it's right side when
you can that's his right just like give
me a second dude
this fight is going really you're gonna
get
[Music]
he's too fast I should see her go to the
right side because he goes over you if
he goes right oh you put a dick [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] he's gonna [ __ ] me up
alright cool he's whipping me check your
health now I can't believe one of those
grenades didn't hit him
my daughter shotgun you know which one
is more powerful honestly I would say
shotgun really yeah close you could go
mine through and start blasting randomly
so it runs into him try not to get
grabbed obviously it sounds obvious does
oh they're exploding like paint him
nice I'm like really worried he's gonna
kill me um okay you get around him just
make sure you run to that side to the
he's facing you right now keep that in
mind good job dodging [ __ ] I'm not gonna
make it
that wasn't bad I think that you
actually got some
dodging down but you [ __ ] you up right
the beginning long-dead screen don't
worry about doing the gun pattern now
right you're not gonna use any of it
just waiting another B to make the
magnum rounds I died a lot if it gets to
the point where this is taking too long
or if you don't want to fight anymore
you could just rely on the magnum rounds
later in the game and not but whatever
you get from them now
but I kind of think you I think you'll
[ __ ] here
it seemed like I could have taken him
out you just gotta you gotta try to do
more of the actual r1 dodging whatever
it's really hard to kill him did you
figure out how to do that dodging yet
yeah it's with my right uh r1 r2 like
when you're already aiming aiming but I
think it's when you start to aim so you
dodge and then she aims I guess are do
you a DS hold inches I held it it was
happening
and it was working
alright let's try this again right so I
need that that's yes you actually need
to time it like a counter-attack which
is what suspected yeah that to bring
that
I have a little bit more it's not a lot
though you got the whole park to do to
so hopefully I'll find stuff in there
and everything dangerous
okay well he'll be [ __ ] dies what time
do we start this episode like quarter
after
it's amazing how long it's taken me to
get anything accomplished this episode
you know what I wonder did you like
litter the rooms mines before you comes
in
oh that's smart I don't know if that's
how it works that I don't really
understand the my therapy I mean I know
how it should work
I don't know resident evil nice now move
like right after you shoot pretty much
be nice I don't know if I'm hitting him
I'm like making assumptions hey you know
I know it's better than getting hit
though you're moving around a lot you've
still gotta [ __ ] little helpless
wait did you equip that
[Music]
it's exploding in his face nice oh [ __ ]
so I would dodge once more before you
shoot oh come on come on
heal up I think you could use a green
come on I don't know why that's so funny
I need a reload while you're here you
might as well oh never mind
oh yeah it's either one of the other I
could switch him that we have six
[Music]
now you can you can just pause reload
later Oh what's he doing Callie I like
don't have enough time he's such a
[ __ ] like we don't have any time it's
late you gotta like get a Shh you got a
shoot after you get a really good
dodging like these are up there there
that's nice run
[Music]
this is a little bit above the 500 you
might have see the green right now
you're fine
so got a full although it sucks cuz if
you're at caution you're on 0 by the way
truck oh sorry i sorry I should have
more specific I don't know what zero
means I can mean anything
don't you know
I wouldn't you know either I ran it up
sorry I'm fine I'm just [ __ ] up now
out of stress I think well I can't stand
so like the whole thing's really [ __ ]
she's goddamn frustrating like I just
feel like if I make one mistake I'm in a
lot of [ __ ] try don't shoot yet nice
see that's a good time to shoot right
after yeah go pick up he should have
dropped something quick quick no he
should have dropped something go you
shouldn't
I don't know what that means I thought I
killed him I could be wrong
[Music]
honey dropping when he fell down not
anymore
[Music]
your son fine yeah but he's gonna [ __ ]
with me but now like I can't do anything
cool against him god [ __ ] you you little
[ __ ] he's still on fine I know but I
don't think I can beat him with my
current setup it's like I have to be so
close to him
like he's gonna kill me he's gonna [ __ ]
I honestly I'm honestly Creek on West
we're side yeah he's tough I thought
when he falls down in a bad mood like I
am broken from this I can't kill him I'm
not good enough or I don't have no right
stuff maybe you could just rely on I am
it I have not prepped for this moment
good enough if I had magnums I think I
could do this
I have some Magnum bullets like I think
I have six I think I like I feel so
[ __ ] defeated from that I had a
really good game I made a lot of really
good moves and I still [ __ ] got
killed and I just like I think I'm just
broken from it honestly I could just
keep I think you were doing well he's
gotta get those dodges down uh when I
liked when he fell to the ground I just
it was like Christmas for nothing
yeah I have six Magnum are you serious
like let's [ __ ] kill him
this isn't like this isn't killing for
good I know but like why are we killing
him at all because it gives you like
rewards and [ __ ] I am I'm not able to
kill him any other way man I know but
you're not you gotta try that other
dodge the the lar want our to dodge I am
I do it all the time I just feel like
I'm not good enough no you're good I
can't do it like that's this is about as
good as I get is what's happening right
now you're witnessing me at my finest
[Music]
I just feel a little broken yeah I don't
think the mindset was that great
I think he's ruined like my
like my attitude in general just filters
the shotgun approach
oh right should I put the mines down now
like we were talking about if that works
I don't know said not to use a shotgun a
couple it's too slow
well what do you want me to do that I'm
out
see it's evening when my drop they're
gonna hurt you - that was the only thing
just make a wallet back up like that I
guess
well
oh no no I do not want to do that
no why
but thank you you want all my minds to
disappear why would they disappear
that's what it just said you're reading
something else yeah you have to add okay
whatever
how are you gonna reload it I can't
until those explode oh I see are you
saying okay gotcha so a real fast
[Music]
crowd I don't think that was good for me
hit him a few times
damnit wrong side [ __ ]
sorry I'm getting frustrated
you have to fight him in this room also
but doesn't it reset wrong time oh you
suck
[Music]
does it reset if I go into another room
I'm so sad right now cat Mouse this
might be tougher actually
I'm so [ __ ] broken inside is a young
okay this is hard I think I'm more room
here you want more room to dodging me
out say sir
[Music]
no I can't afford to miss like I can't
[Music]
she didn't want any profit I like don't
want to play this game anymore
like I think I'm I think I'm done I
can't chew up you don't have I played a
really round one of my grenade launchers
already missed
stop whipping these [ __ ] are you out of
pretty ground I'm out of everything
including hope
he hasn't even gone on the ground yeah
how bad this is good
Rizzy
[Music]
so you were ducking past
[Music]
oh I really cried [ __ ] jib him I just
get [ __ ] [ __ ] thrown around like mud
I can't
[ __ ] you just kill me I'm over it
now you're not even trying I'm broken
I'm actually I'm actually broken like
I'm one understand them like I'm I'm
like mentally defeated it's worth
fighting for the assault rifle I'm not
good enough I keep making mistakes
I could make grenade launcher freeze
rounds to get the assault rifle I don't
think I felt this depressed in a while
it's okay
I have enough see like why don't I just
do it sure like if we want to [ __ ]
kill them give me the necessary things
to kill them because I'm not good enough
to do with what I'm it will have been a
victory if you beat him here obviously
not saying but not according to like my
state of mind - look I've lost more
today than you realize yeah you got a
you know reset yourself before you fight
him no I'm like I'm messed up mentally
they come over it you can't I can't
process sorry
so see and a make what flame do we want
to do that no I do freeze rounds
apparently those are the best
so do a B why are they the best though
because then I can make twenty flame
rounds I just want to be clear here I
can make double that but are they twice
as good how are you make twenty flame
rounds because I have enough agency like
I can combine these cuz then take way
less hits with it's gonna take less hits
with freeze rounds
I'm just saying though it's gonna be a
10/10 freeze rounds is gonna be like
equivalent to more flame rounds and you
want to make this fight as short as
possible you feel yes
confident that look how much a I have I
think you save those because you don't
want the fight to be wanted it has to be
from my understanding of yeah no I am
here I'm just upset also I would not
bring the shotgun I bring the handgun
because you're not getting enough time
to fire off shotgun rounds whereas you
could it's gonna all right so sorry
let's go through this again though how
do I make just combine those two sees
that's it and it just makes the thing
freeze rounds yeah
you've got to use the reloader for women
or whatever it's called relying tool my
heart hurts
like I'm having heart problems
you stopped even trying to do that
regular are to die
honestly like I think he like is
mentally getting to me like a can't yes
he's all up in my [ __ ] face he's
always chasing me like I never get a
second to like think I'm like I'm just
like mentally done like felt like this
and a really a long time but I'm like
really [ __ ] sad games getting to you
hard you'll be alright
how long how many does this hold six
right something like that will I lose
these rounds okay good
that's I'd rather do that then okay what
else did you take so you're telling me I
don't even need my shotgun I think the
mines on the ground were we're not a bad
plan yes I just don't really know cuz
they can hurt you right um but I like
the idea of like prepping that in
advance like I like that I think that
made me feel good that I could do that
but yeah I don't know man I'm pretty sad
that'll be okay I think I wonder if
those damage the damage adds up to each
other or if those are like if he gets
hit with one explosion at a time I don't
know yeah I do I honestly don't know I
got kind of be on the other side to do
this
[Music]
[ __ ] immediately you could go lose him
around the table I can't
[Music]
was I supposed to dodge him there is he
freezing I don't feel like he's freezing
like I just like I'm not good you're
just like getting down as soon as you
get hit
you got no fight left in you or organs
after that I agree I actually think like
this is the worst day of my life oh man
I don't like watching myself diving
you got ahold of crawl out of
better than
or you could just not fight him oh my
god I mean after this like it's just
stupid do you want to try fighting him
one more time and then not fight him did
the mines even do anything
I don't know I'm probably not I don't
think they did anything
snake you're better out dodging my way
just kidding goodnight I am so sad it's
just constantly taking me I think it's
the double hits that are killing me man
yeah but I really think you should just
face him and then when he goes to swing
at you press the r2 thing and then shoot
him right away it takes way too long to
run around and turn ya like running and
turning is not working you know you
gotta make sure you hit the 180s if you
do that but definitely make like just
try to do the regular dodges he's I
don't know if you can dodge the whip I
hate this guy so much thank you I just
come back and get it
I'm gonna die anyway I've lost lost all
hope just a shell of a person this is
how they should torture people who get
caught more just make them play the
Nemesis just break them down slowly and
efficiently [ __ ] I hate you hitting
it did I dodge
ah it's a circle I dodged all right
obviously I don't know how to dodge I
[Music]
know I was there
[Music]
you gotta live if you hit them with the
rest of your fries around you've done
not sure if you've been hurt a week down
honestly okay good to know
I well I don't know for sure about that
[Music]
now I'm out now
I'd rather the flames or the Mayan
thrower no no you got four grenades left
oh right
just keep the you're getting [ __ ] up
every single time when you don't do the
180 right just make sure you know that
and you're fine if you don't now that
just keep running don't try to shoot
[ __ ] stop hitting me
yeah
you got red and green you can use if
your honor gonna hit me
[ __ ] I hate this guy so much
yeah you just closed use that die just
died to side to side
[Music]
sit the game yeah it is come on go it's
over mine throw I don't even know it's
over man ah damn that's close though it
was not fun
yes it was you did him like he was down
I think if you hit him look like two
more grenade rounds or have a couple
more free zones he would have been done
a couple more rounds you could just not
fight him if you want to and save up we
spent the whole episode fighting is why
it was worth it as an experienced let's
cut the episode and that'll be our we'll
crawl out next up so I think you need a
break
oh let's go again he's like the worst
feeling I can't [ __ ] kill this [ __ ]
I actually think you have to be better
at the game and I just don't know what
to do
I can't believe I'm so sad yeah sucks I
wonder if he does take damage when he's
kneeling do you you don't know no that's
what I said like I'm not positive I like
used so much of my health in the last
fight I don't even know if this is worth
it right because like unless he drops
like a [ __ ] ton of health this is all my
health
[Music]
I'm like afraid I'm like screwing myself
for later yeah I guess you might not
find then you just won't have the
assault rifle but whatever we could just
save here and you can go pass him next
time
sleep I just I'm so proud you gonna
fight him one more time I guess try it
out but yeah if you're using too much
health it might be enough I'm using all
my health
this is all the health that I have in
the world and I just like travel with it
do I care it's just my experience
oh come on
I definitely that should not have missed
get in that dark
due to bad chief Todd will turn around
[Music]
see I'm too close to him that time he's
already whipping yeah but I do this 180
like that's why I'm taking all this
damage is because like but it's her
[ __ ] am shooting at him he's he's
whipping me like see that so we're
taking damage for damage which I can't
afford and then I I get myself in these
don't get frustrated I am so frustrated
we're beyond that I don't I don't have
the right technique like I have the
wrong technique
clearly please stop hitting me oh my god
that was good
maybe you should try shooting him now
you might as well
[Music]
hey like this is a mistake
what I'm doing is bad so you out of I'm
out of like everything that Iowa marker
I have nothing left that was good thank
you
when you time the 180 right you're
hitting it easily
[Music]
you just never I don't I I don't do it
enough oh I got caught on the goddamn
pillow bad like this is a really hard
space to fight there's like nothing I
can joke with he's whipping me on the
ground I'm getting caught on everything
it's just like this is like I'm like I
don't think I've ever been like this
defeated like I can't I can't I don't
know what to do and the episode I and
the episode
oh we have to end the episode anyway but
well we'll just run past it next time
we'll save ammo and we'll get him later
fight him later fine later yeah okay
I'm gonna fight it man
if item later I like